I'm singing who's
singing Jewish uh young boy from the
Jewish Family here's the aan look at his
reaction and then we're going to come
and talk about the F what is the
fitra brothers and sisters just imagine
for a second that you give £10 in
donation and that £1 is used to buy food
or bricks or whatever to help the people
in Gaza but then just imagine this
amazing be that you want to do but we
turn it into a money-making machine how
the W is exactly that they take your
money and the money that we are going to
put in in this walk this building and
every single time the money generated
from that W that building is going to go
to our Palestinian brothers and sisters
for the next 20 30 40 50 60 100 150
years and this will be a form of
true click the link below and donate
here is a video that was sent to me by a
Brother D from the Salah plus team and
Subhan Allah just look at this Subhan
Allah this is so amazing that this
Jewish uh young boy from the Jewish
Family hears thean look at his reaction
and then we're going to come and talk
about the F what is the F when the
prophet P told us every believer every
child is born a Muslim this is amazing
brother you cannot make this up there is
so much evidence in that the Quran is
from the true God and it's the truth
here's a clip inshallah and you'll be
amazed and I was going to ask you guys
to follow them on Instagram but sadly I
found out some hypocritical things about
their page which I'm not going to advise
you to guys to do do them neither I
don't do I want you guys to send hate to
them here's the video inah I'm singing
who's
singing
singing are they singing for Hashem
who's singing for Hashem up where is
Hashem up yeah this is people that
believe in AEM also but they're not
Jewish they other
yeah they're called Muslims can can you
say Muslims Muslim yeah and they're
praying to Hashem can you hear
guys you saw that clip Subhan Allah this
is so this is so amazing subh Allah you
always see you saw it in the Dubai Mall
when the child hears the aan and is's
Amazed by it uh to you will hear a
little child a Christian young girl
there was a video and it's talking about
how could Jesus be God it doesn't make
sense and to this Jewish uh I think I'm
assuming it's a boy young I don't know
yeah this child todra who's there and
they hear thean what is the thir thing
they say hasham is basically what they
God cuz they cannot mention God's actual
name it's they see it very holy so they
don't even mention the name yeah so
saying Hashem is singing or it's they're
singing for hash automatically they
connected the young child hears the aan
and automatically connects you know
children are very innocent they say
things you know they will say some some
some say some mad stuff yeah but it's
the truth they see what happens in the
house Etc yeah so when a child says
something you're like whoa do you get it
that you know that's one place of truth
cuz a a child cannot be you know
manipulated in that way so you can see
directly when they hear it when the
child is hearing the aan they could have
say anything they could have say oh it's
from uh Satan it's from a bad person
it's the Boogyman or whatever no from
who from Hashem to them who it is Allah
yes okay to us it's Allah subhana tala
yeah okay um in in the aspect so Subhan
Allah they qu and the prophet P told us
that every child is born a Muslim on the
F unless that when they grow up their
family make them a Jew they make them a
Christian or make them an idol worshiper
etc etc etc other than that they are
born with the F the innate inclination
the innate disposition to believe in a
higher power there was a study done in
Oxford University by Justin Barrett he
found the same results that if you left
a child without external influence of
any religion they would go up finding or
knowing that God exists there is a
higher power not they will not come and
say Jesus is God or this person is God
no no no they will know that there's a
higher power Subhan Allah yeah so this
shows you that subh Allah and not only
that what did the child say if you
listen closely said what Hashem up and
this is the same thing when a slave girl
came to the prophet peace be upon him
and the prophet peace be upon Him asked
him about you know about Allah I don't
know if he said where is Allah I'm not
coming but she pointed up yes and that
was sufficient enough for her IM to
testify that her IM is in the right
place yeah okay now obviously we don't
say Allah is in a Direction but you get
the gist the gist is that he's powerful
it could mean it symbolize many things
Etc okay before the people come and say
oh what if she was in Australia and
pointing down Etc okay so the the point
is that we don't believe Allah is
direction for that matter yeah but
that's what it proved now I was going to
get you guys obviously to follow this
family they seem like the reason I don't
if they live in Israel I don't think
they do for that matter yeah but here is
a video that I saw and I thought to
myself come on it's a bit hypocritical I
mean I mean let's quickly watch this
yeah before cuz I don't want to ruin
this whole video it was a very nice
video Etc but check out what is it about
today you know for now for 6 months
already there is a friends of us that
used to live in Israel and then nothing
isra anymore can you think about it
someone who was living in a house and
now they're not in their house anymore
and they really want to come back do you
want them to come back also
no that my friend you want your friends
to come back friends who want to go back
to their mommy when you go to G you want
to come back to your mommy so also our
friends they want to come back to their
mommy already and it's been 6 months
that they haven't seen their mommy is it
sad that they can't see their
mommy yeah what can we do to make them
happy and out
and want to go really want to go yeah
they really want to go back right so we
need to pray pray for them yeah so I
find it very uh ironic and bizarre that
they are talking about there's this
group of friends of they've been left
Etc they're talking about the hostages
yes there's also hostages uh thousands
of them who are locked up in Israel not
only that it's very very ironic that
you're talking about some of our friends
that have gone you know they've been
kicked out of their
houses hello do you hello like do when
you say this do you think you know uh
you know this what exactly Israel done
to the Palestinians they have been
kicked out of their houses yeah you
forgot the nakba hello hi I find it very
bizarre I find it like really like are
you like are you um oblivious to this or
on purpose yeah you're talking about the
hostages Yes
again what we're seeing is that group of
thousands of Palestinians yes hostage
should be released as well but the point
is this okay those hostage are being
taken much better care than these people
that some of the world they them to a
terrorist than the Israel Democratic
country that has ever treated broken
arms rape all this kind of stuff so
Subhan Allah it's very bizarre so again
I'm not going to ask you guys to follow
this family because it seems very
hypocritical but I just wanted to
highlight the Jewish boy and his fitra
you can see his f is on what Islam is
that the moment he hear thean he
connects directly to Allah subhana tala
hash that's what they call it that's all
I want to say brother sisters enjoy this
video inah do not forget to donate to
the W in the end inshallah may Allah
bless and preserve you guys please share
this video far and wide Islam is the H
and is the truth and you can see even
from children How could a child know
that that is from Allah that is from God
Almighty when he hears the Adan and
doesn't it doesn't connect it anywhere
else that's all I want to say brother
sisters brothers and sisters just
imagine for a second that you give £10
in donation and that £10 is used to buy
food or bricks or whatever to help the
people in Gaza but then just imagine
this amazing de that you want to do but
we turn it into a money-making machine
how the W is exactly that they take your
money and the money that we are going to
put in in this W this building and every
single time the money generated from
that W that building is going to go to
our Palestinian brothers and sisters for
the next 20 30 40 50 60 100 150 years
and this will be a form of
true I myself will be donating for that
inshah click the link below and donate
may Allah subhana bless and preserve you
guys